粉丝量足够大，
但我直播间人足够多了之后，
这对于我来说的话，
也是我自己的一个弊端，
其实我特别能理解大家，
因为涉及的都是一些婚姻的事儿啊，
隐私的事儿啊，
感情的事儿啊，
不太愿意被剪辑，
不太愿意被公开，
我也能理解大家，
但对于我来说啊，
我为什么要剪辑出这些作品出来呢？
是因为有成千上万个人会跟大家有相同的困惑，
有一样的问题，
但是并不是所有人都有这个经济条件，
可以花300块钱来问龙飞姐，
那么我把这个跟千千万万个人相同的类似的问题的回答我都捡出来，
免费的发到平台上，
就等于可以有千千万万的受众，
他可以不花一分钱就能解决当下的困惑，
包括一些法律知识，
包括一些两口子的婚姻家庭的这些矛盾，
他就能找到答案，
所以这件事情我们一直坚持在做，
就是自私的说法的话，
把这些比较有共鸣的这些故事减出来，
也可以增加我的这种曝光度，
增加我的流量，
也可以增加还没有认识我的粉丝对我的这样一个信任度，
确实是主观上来说的话，
我是自私的，
我必须要把这些故事捡出来，
才能让更多的人相信我愿意在我直播间来消费，
愿意在我直播间来花钱，
这是我自私的一个出发点，
但是客观上来讲的话，
这些故事确实帮助了千千万万。
个经济条件不好的男男女女吧，
我不知道这么说大家有没有感觉，
因为有很多姐妹，
她可能一个月就挣个2000块钱，
你让她花300块钱来问我的话，
这是非常困难的，
但是她可以通过免费的来看这些剪出来的故事，
他可以得到成长，
他可以吸收养分，
他可以不花钱就能够解决他当下的问题，
这是一个客观的对不想被剪辑是很正常的，
我也理解啊，
相互之间理解，
我们就是说到明处，
就比如说这个东西的话，
我一直都贴在这，
就不介意被剪辑的朋友来连一直都贴在这儿，
这个也是我做到的一个义务，
就是让大家心里有数啊。